[Music]
hey everybody what's going on yeah what
the hell is today tuesday yeah it's
tuesday
[Laughter]
see if they're all coming in everybody's
coming in that's good hey what's going
on you guys yeah
give him a few more seconds all right
so we saw this one um
i guess it was yeah last night wasn't it
no it was the night before last year
for the night before last
and it's free
on um
it was amazon amazon wasn't it yeah it
was amazon prime yeah amazon prime okay
i didn't know if it was on that uh that
hbo one that you had but yeah amazon
and um
almost didn't watch it just scrolling
through
it the little the little
[ __ ]
ad that they had for it what do you call
it
with a little graphic the little
thumbnail yeah the thumbnail it didn't
look too exciting and like terrible
terrible title
but then i read the captions of what it
said said it was post-apocalyptic
so we clicked it on and it sucked me in
man i got it i and i like this movie it
was real good
i did as well it's really weird because
i never this came out in 2018 yeah it's
called i think we're alone now so yeah
now i've got that [ __ ] tiffany song
stuck in my head although like i said
it's not technically a tiffany song it's
a cover like i think the original was by
tommy james and the shondelles but
anyway so uh so it gets stuck in my head
but
this came out 2018 has peter dinklage in
it for christ's sake has l fanning in it
for christ's sake uh paul giamatti is in
this briefly i think charlotte
gainsbourg there's only like four people
in it um but
i had did not hear about this movie yeah
never at all we honestly we just came
across it when we were we were just like
scrolling through like randomly just
looking for some random [ __ ] to watch
yeah and tom was like ooh
post-apocalyptic cause he loves those
and i was like oh peter dinklage is in
it i really like him well he was on game
of thrones i saw him um
actually the first time i saw him in a
movie was way back in
2003 i think it was the station agent
which you have you haven't seen that
that's fantastic this movie kind of
reminded me a little bit of that but
that's not post-apocalyptic obviously
but he was playing like a similar kind
of character if i remember correctly
but and l fanning i remembered her she
started out as a child star but i
remembered her from the neon demon
because i just saw that like not too
long ago
i didn't know any of the any of the
names you know what
and when it started it just
i'm like what the hell is this about
because
when we were when it started i was like
well if it's no good we'll just watch
another one we'll we'll ch yeah we had
about we had a backup
[Laughter]
but i was like two minutes into it and i
was already getting pulled into it i was
like i got a feeling this is a good
movie and 15 minutes into it because man
this is an interesting movie i've never
seen anything like this
um
it starts out just a sleepy town it
looks like new england somewhere yeah i
think it might be upstate new york yeah
and it's just still
kind of like got some out of the omega
man
and there's one dude left
and he's a dwarf
um and he's doing weird [ __ ] he's going
into houses he's cleaning them up
he's marking off what houses he's been
to and [ __ ] spray painting in the
ground kind of like omega man except
he's going in there and cleaning he's
going there and cleaning he's taking all
the dead bodies and he's taking he's
burying them all
and he doesn't say anything
and then one day he finds a [ __ ] car
wreck and then there's a [ __ ] pretty
young girl in there
so he
next scene you see she wakes up she's in
bed he's got a bandage
and or she's got a bandage on her head
and she's locked into the room
he's on the other side of the door you
know and he's what are you doing here
you know that kind of stuff he thought
he was alone
evidently and um
he was kind of afraid to let her out and
then she kind of made a joke oh i
thought you'd be shorter you know
you sounded shorter right you sounded
short because she didn't see him she was
unconscious when he found her so then
this like he's trying to tell her to
beat it this is his town you know get
out of here type of deal you know but
she stays and they kind of
kind of have like a friendship but it
takes a while because this dude doesn't
[ __ ] talk man he's real introverted
you know he's well he kind of likes
solitude yeah well i think like what
they're getting at it's not real like
heavy-handed with this but i think what
they're getting at is that because
he was a dwarf he probably got [ __ ] on
like most of his life like got picked on
and stared at and stuff and it's like
now because he does make a kind of
couple comments about that but it's like
now that everybody's dead he's like true
finally like i can finally get some
[ __ ] quiet and nobody will pick on me
and i can just like run around and do
what the hell i want yeah that that's
part of the story but yeah we're a
friend of mine's a little person you
know he he works at uh orlando [ __ ]
universal universal yeah uh and he's
also worked in disney's name tito and we
he hangs out the club
and uh no you know if you
if you know any little people man they
are all [ __ ] ego okay and they got to
be the only little person around if
there's more than one i'm around they
goes oh look i
they are the biggest [ __ ] haters man
although that might be like
in this movie yeah it's like this writ
large it's like well everybody's gone so
now i'm the only but because he thinks
that he's the only person left on earth
now what killed everybody else
you're led to believe it was some kind
of pandemic it wasn't like a nuclear war
or anything because everything's still
standing but it looks like whatever it
was it must have been some kind of like
disease
it must have happened really fast
because when he goes in like to clean
houses up like some people were just
like sitting at their dinner table and
like died like they didn't fall on the
floor or nothing yeah so it must have
happened like really really quickly
yeah i'm not sure it was a disease
it was something
because when you looked at it some of
those bodies
died at the dinner table as if they
didn't even feel like they were sick
yeah it was almost kind of made me think
it may have been something like uh what
do you call that [ __ ] um it's when a
star explodes and then a
in a neutrino burst
that's what it's called they've actually
thought that that might happen that a
neutrino bur that the earth could get
caught in a neutrino burst and it would
kill everybody that was unprotected
you know so maybe the people that
survived were just in a place at a
certain time that protected them from
the neutrinos because it looked like
they were just zapped
yeah and nobody looked like i mean some
of the people were like just in bed like
you said something people were just
sitting at the table they look like they
were doing normal she was doing normal
[ __ ] yeah they just looked like they
died without warning and evidently it
all happened at exactly the same time
everywhere it happened in a day
yeah i mean i think they don't i mean
she doesn't really say like how long ago
it was it seems like it was quite a
while ago because they weren't that
rotten so about a year yeah maybe
something like that like some of the
bodies looked like they were decayed and
like started to mummify a little bit a
little bit right they were dry they
weren't wet yeah so it had obviously
been long enough for them to all kind of
like it look more like because the way
the bodies where i would say it was
something exotic they never say what it
is because they don't know what it was
it was but i think it might have been
something yeah but he's basically just
like like a neutrino burst yeah he's
just like everybody just died and he
yeah yeah which that's possible
yeah you know
i don't know if it would all happen in
one day because the earth has to rotate
yeah inside the burst yeah but i mean i
don't want to spoil too much about where
this goes right so whatever it was some
people survived it yeah
and um
the movie kind of
goes along kana
slow
but it keeps your attention because
stuff is happening through the whole
thing and and it feels like something is
going to happen
and eventually it does but i don't want
to [ __ ] spoil it man this is because
i don't think many many people saw this
movie yeah i haven't even like heard of
it and it just seemed like and then when
it came out like i found a few reviews
of it most of which were
very meh yeah um you know what i mean
people were just like well you know the
acting's good and everything but it does
there's not much there there there is
there there yeah i think it's very
subtle and it's kind of like more a
character piece i think it's it's
realistic i don't know if it like
necessarily sold itself as like being
science fiction it does have a
sprinkling of science fiction yeah but i
think it's more
like a character study or like a drama
and it's kind of talking about and you
know for the first like 20 25 minutes of
the movie it's just peter dinklage so
he's not like he thinks he's the only
person left on earth so it's like he's
not talking he's just going about his
normal daily routine
yeah i mean
and he um he he almost kind of is like
he keeps trying like he goes in
everybody's house cleans up the bodies
buries the bodies and he cleans the
house up like you know he just sprays
and cleans and bleaches and everything
like that and then he takes all their
photos
and files them like he lives in the
town's library yeah because he's real
and and i don't know if he was a
librarian before whatever happened
happened i'm guessing he probably was
but he lives in the library so he goes
and like
brings the books back and he keeps them
like almost like um
like it's a working library like he
keeps it all catalogued he keeps
everything cataloged so i'm assuming
that he did live in the library before
yeah so so he's just been going along
and he's just like seems perfectly fine
that he's that there's nobody left on
earth he's just kind of having his
little life and he's just like us he is
nice kind of the me
it's nice and quiet when you watch the
movie when you get to the end you
realize that what what the movie's about
is that the main theme of the story
is that if it if if a disaster
happens
the survivors okay are going to fall in
a couple different um categories
you're going to have some people who
accept the new situation for how it is
and enjoy it
you're gonna have other people
that try to recapture the past and
rebuild the past even if that wasn't all
that good you know or even if that's not
possible to recapture the past
um because
face it you know i mean a lot of people
like what what's happening now because
they have
a lot of kind of say
they have a status in life that gives
them
feelings of self-worth in other words
they're you know the house that they
live in the profession that they have
the respect that they have from the
community and you know the quote-unquote
being normal i guess you could say or
being respectable
well if most people are dead and you
only got a you know a couple hundred
thousand survivors in the world
what would it matter
you know what none of that would matter
you could have anybody could have the
best house they'd ever wanted just by
just walking up into it
you know
a lot of things wouldn't have
a lot of things wouldn't be that
valuable because they would everything
would be plentiful
the survivors were kind of in a land of
plenty they could do and they were very
free
you didn't need a profession per se
people just did [ __ ] that they wanted to
do like he didn't have to clean up the
damn town
yeah but that's what he wanted to do
right he didn't have to like catalog all
the books or their photos but he wanted
to right and no one was around to tell
him not to no that's how he wanted to
spend his life and that was and i think
he lived in the library didn't he yeah
that's what he said he slept he wouldn't
even his old house was there he didn't
go into it and yeah he didn't take a
mansion or anything
so well he's doing what he wants to do
and everybody else is doing what they
want to do and it looks very different
because there are other people
but you find out at the end of the movie
what the other people are doing
and um
yeah you know there's there's gonna
there's another group of survivors
that's basically trying to recreate the
past even though they don't have to
it's like an article that's kind of like
yeah don't say too much more than that
because it's like it's not i wouldn't
call it like a big twist or anything
like that but because mostly like i said
the first 20 minutes or so like peter
dinklage it's kind of established that
you know he lives in the lab he just
lives a very quiet life he seems you
know maybe not happy but he seems like
content like you know this is fine um
like i said he wasn't seemed like he
wasn't a real social person before so
he's just like oh it's nice and quiet
you know he goes out fishing and after
he's done cleaning people's houses for
the day he goes out fishing and gets
some fish and brings it back and cooks
his food and everything like that and he
seems like perfectly happy and then like
one night he's actually woken up like
before the car wreck he's actually woken
up by fireworks remember that he sees
fireworks like across the lake and he's
like what the [ __ ] is that all about
yeah and then like the next day he hears
a car alarm yeah um and he goes and he
finds like this car has like gone up on
a curb or like hit a pole or something
like that and he finds like elle fanning
her name's grace his name's dell
actually yeah and um and she's like
unconscious and so he does take her back
to his to the library and like you know
fixes her up and everything but after
that he's just kind of like yeah you
need to get the [ __ ] out because they
had kind of like liked my life but she's
like no man i want to hang out here and
she's like the complete polar opposite
to him she's very boisterous and she's
very loud yeah she reminds me of our
friend kaley yeah she's just kind of
like
she's very fun she's very bubbly like
way yey you know what i mean trying to
make fun because there was nothing to do
yeah and then she finds a puppy and he
you can tell that he's just kind of like
[ __ ] this you know what i mean because
he's just like was so used to his
solitude and there's comes this girl
just like messing everything up and when
he found her in the car knocked out
because she ran into it was it wasn't a
fire hydrant was it
it might have been a fire hydrant or i
think it was yeah i don't think it was a
pole pole but it hit something i guess
she fell asleep behind the wheel or
something
that i don't think was ever clear or she
just wrecked the car somehow
driving like a maniac
um in the back seat was a she had a
stainless revolver back there
and i think it kind of spoke to him at
first and later on he says what do you
have a gun for
yeah there's like nobody around and he's
just in case i need
see you know in case i need to protect
myself he goes there's nobody here yeah
from who yeah
because
there was nobody around as far as he was
as far as he knew hadn't seen anybody
which was kind of a good survival
survivalist twist
because in most other post-apocalyptic
movies you know they're they're armed up
most of the characters yeah because
there are
[ __ ] survivors this dude's convinced
that there's nobody really there's not
enough yeah he doesn't really have to
worry about it which in a situation
that's being portrayed in this
particular post-apocalyptic story
is plausible
the collapse happened so fast there was
no chaos everyone was killed yeah so
what was left was just
a few survivors they'd be happy to see
each other
yeah there'd be no reason to fight
everything is just for the taking so you
don't have to steal anything or kill
anybody to get anything
you can just walk right into a grocery
store and they were just [ __ ] canned
food all over the shelves yeah because
they showed like at one point him and
grace go in there and obviously some of
the stuff is spoiled you can't eat it
not the cancer but not the cans and it's
just like it didn't look like they'd
been looting or anything so whatever
happened like happened immediately
immediately because nobody everything is
just laying right there so there was no
environmental pressure on anybody so it
would be peaceful
in that in that circumstances
uh at least for the most part you know
but you know complications happen later
in the movie yeah uh which is
another
thing that might happen in a situation
like this i thought it was a very good
movie it was uh i did too i thought it
was a good move it's a good idea it
didn't go in the direction that i was
expecting which i liked no there was
certain parts that certain aspects of
the story kind of reminded me of a more
realistic
kind of a
simplified version of the boy and his
dog they had [ __ ] don johnson there's
another
movie you never see that one because the
character in that one had a robotic dog
who was old police dog and don johnson
who's this post-apocalyptic
post-apocalyptic teenage kid all his
whole purpose was just to run around
rape and kill girls
yeah that's a
wild movie
and um whereas this character just wants
to like live in his library and eat some
fish
have on and enjoy the quiet yeah
which you know i feel that
that's probably what i'd be doing to you
to be honest with you i'm just like hey
it's so nice and quiet everyone's gone
and
a boy and his dog there's one group of
survivors that are trying to rebuild the
1950s 1950s country life which is kind
of like certain certain people in this
movie are trying to rebuild the lives
that they had
and
they're going to do it through
unconventional means it's it's it's
pretty good yeah so yeah like i said i
didn't really expect it to go in that
direction so i kind of like liked it i
forgot to mention that the director of
this
uh her name is reed morano
and she was also the cinematography
cinematographer which is significant
because the cinematography in this is
like really really nice very very good
with the world building
she um she's directed a lot of things
but i think she's probably most famous
for doing the pilot episode of the
handmaid's tale uh you know the series
which i love that so i thought that was
like super cool i didn't know that she
had directed this movie like when i
first started watching it can i also say
the score of this
i
loved this
you know what it reminded me of it
reminded me of did you guys watch that
german series that was on netflix called
dark
the score reminded me of that it was
like really really ominous
and i really really dug it like i
thought it was really good but yeah it's
this like i said don't go into this
thinking it's going to be some
action-packed it is a slow burn it's
like a character study more than
anything
and it's post-apocalyptic but it's and
it has a little bit of sci-fi like a
sci-fi angle to it but it's not like
it's got a last man on earth fantasy
element to it though look at what i do
and this and that you can think about it
it's well thought out it's not
hokey it's well thought out
uh it's realistic for the situation
that's being shown if everybody would
die like in one day
yeah that's what it would be like yeah
um
i liked everything about it oh i didn't
like it was a title i don't i think the
title did not do the movie justice
you you hear the title and you don't
know what kind of movie that is it
almost sounds like it might be a
romantic comedy or something i don't
think it fit the movie yeah and it's not
really
i mean because they don't really i mean
there is like a little bit do you want
to say there's like a little bit of a
romance i guess but it's not really
that's not really like the main point of
the movie it's kind of more like a
friendship really right um you know what
i mean like as they and they're kind of
like an odd couple because he's like
very very stoic and quiet and kind of
cranky and she's like very bubbly and
outgoing yeah but he was also
not really up to the task when it came
to bravery
he had to kind of think about this [ __ ]
and [ __ ] he wasn't there for her he
had to come back and he had to man up
and resolve it go get her type of deal
she said what was what had happened he
rejected that but you got to see the
movie yeah and i think it was i leave
her he didn't believe yeah i think it
was more more a sense that he didn't
believe her he thought she was full of
[ __ ] and he's like oh you're just
another one of those people that like
yeah you know just right but he had to
get but no he had to become the hero
yeah and yeah so i so i kind of think
that he was just kind of like oh you're
just like all the other ones get the
[ __ ] out of here cast was [ __ ] good i
thought it was casted well
acting was real good
um
just i liked it it was good movie yeah i
tried to own this i'd own this movie i
i'll get this on blu-ray eventually put
you in my collection it's interesting
because it's gonna be one of those
unappreciated movies it's well yeah it
definitely is because i like i said
there's not a huge amount of reviews of
it and the written reviews that i saw
um were mostly like pretty mixed on it
they were kind of like oh the
cinematography is nice and the concept
is nice and the acting is good but they
didn't really think there was that much
substance to it but i disagree i think
there was a lot of stuff going on it's
visual understanding yeah it's showing
you situations and you have to
have empathy for the characters and put
yourself in in that position and also
if you have a good history of other
post-apocalyptic movies you'd understand
what you understand what you're being
shown yeah because you have other things
to compare it to the differences in the
situations of how it started you know
that guy i
i thought he did a good job yeah i mean
um it's not a big budget movie
oh
yeah obviously it's an independent film
but that's great yeah so but if you want
to do a post-apocalyptic movie you do it
like this yes that's how you do it it
doesn't cost a whole lot of money but i
still got that feeling
that he was in an empty city by himself
so that's perfect
yeah i mean yeah this is this is
definitely how you do something on like
a low budget
um you know and i mean she was lucky
because she got really good actors too
you know i mean that was probably like
there is actually in this movie a um
an opening for a sequel
you could you could you could expand
this out you could expand it yeah it's a
situation similar to stephen king's the
stand
in a popular yeah we kind of said this
could almost be in the same universe
you're right the difference was that in
this in the stand they did die quickly
so there was a lot of stuff laying
around yeah um the pandemic i think took
place in about a week or so i think
pretty much
pretty much everyone was dead in a week
or so so there wasn't
there wasn't a lot of chaos at warfare
before they were all dead just so
yeah this one it seemed to happen in one
day but it's a similar it seems like it
could be a similar universe i'm not
talking about like the you know the
revelation aspect with god the devil and
all that you know but i'm just saying
the way the civilians were and the way
the situation is of an empty world
about like that it could be almost in
the same
it could have been in the same
universe just off to the side somewhere
and nobody not knowing that that town
was even there
yeah that's what i'm saying that's
that's kind of like the impression yeah
of it
he was just because it was a small town
they had they said hey you said how many
people it was 1600 1600 that's how many
people lived in the town they were all
dead that was his town he stayed there
yeah so because why would he leave i
mean you know
it's funny because when he first meets
grace
she's saying oh i've been driving around
the country
going to all the landmarks like she was
she said she was on her way to um
niagara falls
like she was going around like looking
all this stuff but then she decided to
like stay with him instead so
like i said there's a lot of stuff
there's not a huge amount of dialogue
but i feel like there's a lot of stuff
going on like underneath the surface
yeah like with the visuals and john said
he saw it didn't understand the end
yeah well you gotta i i kind of
mentioned it earlier on i don't know
when you showed up but um there's a
meaning to it
you know
some people will try to re-embrace
rebuild the past that they lost
and if they have to do unethical things
to to rebuild a past
they'll do that
the way they were
you know some people will want to
recapture their
social standing and status in life by
living a
a suburban middle class life with you
know
careers and
social status and
neighbors and mowing lawns and [ __ ] and
not all that would be obsolete you could
go out and live in any mansion you
wanted to you didn't have to work
everything was for free
you know there was [ __ ] sounds coming
decades and decades of [ __ ] food and
equipment
out there you know they were stealing
solar panels to get
electric power and you know just
when you have such a rapid population
reduction
there isn't any stress on the people
you know yeah
cans of food everywhere
yeah i mean live for decades yeah if it
was just one person you'd never run out
and he would and he went fishing like he
would go fishing because i guess it
didn't kill the animals yeah and there'd
be abandoned towns and cities all over
north america
you know
you couldn't eat everything
canned food will stay good for decades
and decades yeah
like i said you'd never run out no and
then wildlife would take over the deer
hunting and the fishing would be great
you'd have cows walking around
you'd probably turn it yeah you didn't
see a lot of animals like you there was
like at one point where they found a
puppy and he did seem to go fishing
every day because he seemed like really
like well he was using chopsticks and
stuff i guess he was making so he was
making fish like all the time uh sly
said i would see it just because of paul
giamatti he's not in it a lot he's like
more in it toward the end
so he's kind of like a minor role in it
uh and asks where was it filmed i think
like i said i think it's supposed to be
upstate new york although i'm not
entirely sure if that's where they feel
and then some of it i think might
supposed to be palm springs i don't know
if it is palm springs but i think it's
supposed to be yeah because a lot of
times i think with things that are
supposed to be upstate new york like a
lot of times they'll film it in canada
yeah but maybe not i mean maybe they
filmed this in a real ghost town i'm not
entirely sure because it doesn't look
like they did a lot of like set dressing
or anything but
i don't know i'd have to like look that
up i don't even think it says because i
have like some notes from the wikipedia
page but i don't think it says
where they shot it interestingly but i'm
sure i could find out it might be on
imdb or something
yeah but yeah so
uh you have anything else no that's
awesome
and yeah like i said i don't really want
to spoil it because i feel like a lot of
people haven't seen it and i didn't
really expect it to go in the direction
that it went in and i was like so i was
kind of like oh okay we're doing this
that's like that's weird
i'm kind of into it if you see it again
he says
everything is said it's just that
sometimes it's said
and you got to pick up on what was said
about people being paired up and it's
just you know they were it was an
artificially assembled type situation
yeah yeah yeah
all right so that'll do it for today
now tomorrow is our main show episode
306 and we are gonna do should be a fun
one we're gonna do uh history of we're
gonna talk about spiritualism and
seances yeah which i've been wanting to
do this one for a while so because i
love all this stuff about seances okay
[ __ ] i think we've i think we've
covered some somewhere we've covered
like some kind of like spiritualism
topics before because i think we did we
talked about like the philip experiment
we've talked about like other things
like kind of around it i think a long
time ago we did a show about houdini
uh and about how he would go
demonstrances and stuff but that was so
long ago and i don't think we've ever
done one experiment yeah that's the one
i was thinking yeah yeah yeah uh but
yeah so that'll be uh tomorrow so
hopefully you guys can come by for that
because like i said i think it'll be a
good time so thanks for dropping by
today and we will see you guys again
tomorrow